Can you say a little bit about how social networks fit into the history
of the use of technology in political protests?
Right. This is a really an interesting topic in that with the dictators,
what they want is a lot of people to believe that everybody is happy
with what's going on.
They don't want a lot of people to know that people are unhappy.
What happened was during the 1979 Iranian revolution,
people were passing information through cassettes,
for those of us who are old enough to know what cassettes are.
During the Tiananmen Square uprising, people were passing information through fax
and with the use of fax machines.
Now, with smart phones and Twitter and Facebook,
people can pass information very rapidly,
so I would know if there was a protest how many of my friends are going to go
or how many people will go.
If I feel like a good mass of people are going to go
and that we can really damage the government, then I would go.
We have models that show whether the particular movement will spread
or whether it will stop and so on and so forth.
It's very exciting work.
Network science and social network analysis has come into service here,
because if you think about cybersecurity, what is cybersecurity?
What is cyber? Cyber is just a collection of machines that are networked together.
I send an email from my machine and so on and so forth,
and that's then an information network.
Underlying it is a physical network of machines that are linked to each other.
You can think of it, well, if I'm a bad guy, and I want to spread a virus through this network,
how will I do it?
It's similar to this idea of epidemiology like between people networks
and how does it spread and whether you are more susceptible to get a virus than not.
If your PC is more prevalent, maybe you're more susceptible
to some of the viruses that are out there, because the majority of viruses
are for PCs right now and less for Macs.
Or, for example, if I'm a good guy, how would I stop a virus from spreading?
Which links should I take away or which nodes should I take away?
Nodes here being computers, right?
Actually, this also is analogous to people networks.
If I don't want a piece of information to spread, which person should I take out?
For some definition of take out.
I've been watching a lot of murder mysteries.
You have worked for the government.
So, this is how it comes in cybersecurity,
and in fact if you think about it
social networks are built on top of information networks
and that's built on top of physical networks,
and so the interdependency between these networks is very interesting to study
and see, well, if I take out part of a physical network
how will that affect the information network and the social network.
In fact, we have seen recently, for example again, with the demonstrations
when the governments take down their Internet,
because they don't want people to talk to each other,
but we're seeing that even though they take down the Internet,
because there's a phone network and the Twitter apps and all these other apps,
are also through phones and voice that people can communicate information now,
which is awesome.